[Musik]
willkommen zur sternstunde religion die
verzweiflungstat eines einzelnen löst
eine massenbewegung in weiten teilen der
arabischen welt aus am 14 januar 2011
liegt der junge gemüsehändler mohamed
bouazizi seinen schweren verbrennungen
die er sich selbst zugefügt hat das volk
geht auf die straße
der tunesische diktator ben ali geht aus
dem amt gejagt und wenige wochen später
trat auch der ägyptische langzeit
präsident hosni mubarak nach anhaltenden
protesten ab das war vor zehn jahren die
hoffnung auf grundlegenden wandel der
auch mehr selbstbestimmung für frauen
bedeuten würde
ging als arabischer frühling in die
geschichte ein
und um den geht es in der heutigen
sendung bei mir sind die
islamwissenschaftlerin und
politikwissenschaftlerin eliane edmüller
und die journalistin und arabistik
monika poliker ganz herzlich willkommen
eliane edmüller sie waren ab märz 2011
in kairo sie haben an der uni dort
gearbeitet hatten ihr doktorat ort
geschrieben
sie haben viel filmisches material auch
selbst gedreht über die zeit der
proteste und der unmittelbaren zeit nach
der absetzung dann und wir schauen uns
jetzt ein paar bilder an die sie uns
mitgebracht haben uns bitte sie das
sieht nicht kommentieren
dieser hier sieht man im märz anfangs
märz war der tarif von sämtlichen
politischen parteien in beschlag
genommen wo junge leute sich selbst
organisiert haben zb hier bei der ein
tipp kontrolle dadurch sucht eine junge
ägypterin die den die handtasche einer
anderen später hat man natürlich auch
für jetzt die das allgemein allgemeine
bedürfnisse gesorgt hier werden haare
geschnitten ganz anderes als jetzt in
der kroner zeit bei uns diese jungen
männer waren dann auch fasziniert von
der idee im schweizer fernsehen zu
kommen was ich habe mich vom schweizer
team vorgestellt haben auch das franken
sie ganz toll hier ein mann beim gebet
man sieht wirklich sämtliche sämtliche
glaubens und ideologischen ausrichtung
politischen ausrichtungen der
ägyptischen revolution waren vertreten
kurz jetzt noch mal zurück dann bild
davor das habe ich jetzt leider noch
nicht kommentieren könnt das war die
mauer der märtyrer die damals gestorben
sind und das ist vielleicht auch gleich
noch mal wichtig das zu erwähnen also
diese ägyptische revolution war obwohl
sie vielfach auch sogar dargestellt
wurde natürlich nicht gewaltlos die
hauptsächliche gewalt ging natürlich von
den sicherheits einheiten des regimes
aus die ganz unterschiedlicher gestalt
waren und entsprechend sind mindestens
900 menschen in der zeit gestorben
wir werden sicher darauf auch noch
zurückkommen aber zunächst einmal ganz
persönlich sie haben jetzt dieses
material selbst fast zehn jahren nicht
mehr angesehen was ist ihm da ganz
persönlich durch den kopf gegangen als
sie das jetzt wieder angeschaut haben
also es war für mich ein sehr
emotionales erlebnis als zu der zeit bin
ich nach ägypten gereist ich hatte schon
vorher einige aufenthalte in ägypten
hinter mich gebracht ich habe insgesamt
eher jahre im land gelebt dass immer in
kleinen hinauf enthalten also und dann
ausgedehnt auf fünf jahre vom vom sommer
2007 bis ende 2012 und konnte die
entwicklung eigentlich sehr gut
mitverfolgen ende mubarak-regime und
dann nachher über die revolution hinweg
und zu dem zeitpunkt als die revolution
ausbrach also am 15 25 januar mit dem
sogenannten
das war der tag des zorns wo eben
aufgerufen worden ist das ägyptische
bürger hin und bürger gegen das regime
demonstrieren gehen sollen zu dem
zeitpunkt befand ich mich in heidelberg
und war gerade dabei mich vorzubereiten
auf meinen nächsten aufenthalt in
ägypten
ich war dabei eine dissertation arbeit
zu schreiben an der universität
heidelberg und zwar zu themen eigentlich
der ersten ägyptischen nationalistischen
revolution 18 81 angeführt von öffnet
oder obi und was mich fasziniert hat zu
der zeit weil ich habe dann am tag
eigentlich immer zu natürlich diesen
themen gearbeitet und nachts nicht
verfolgt was jetzt gerade auf dem tag da
hier passiert und da waren ähnliche
slogans wie damals da waren ähnliche
bedürfnisse damals waren ähnliche
politische repräsentanten wie damals
also vielleicht um das ganz schnell noch
zu erwähnen dass es war damals schon die
karikatur kam zu dem zeitpunkt also am
ende des 19 jahrhunderts aus sehr sehr
wichtiges medium der arabischen krise
eigentlich auf das war der anfang später
werden wir das wahrscheinlich im verlauf
das gericht auch noch mal sehen wurden
diese karikaturen sehr wichtig auch für
die jüngsten revolutionären bewegung und
hier haben wir eine karikatur aus dem
jahr 18 79 und da wird bereits
eigentlich gezeigt welche politischen
akteure auch schon damals vorhanden
waren
es waren die fälle das waren dass die
bauern die repräsentanten des
ägyptischen volkes und gleichzeitig
waren dass die dort die offiziere das
militär und als dritte wichtige mächtige
instanz im land wurden die uhr also die
religiösen um die religiösen theologen
und vertreter der ausfahrt schon bereits
damals gehandelt deshalb war das für
mich natürlich faszinierend zu sehen wie
diese bewegung eigentlich auch weiter
sich überschneiden und nicht zuletzt
natürlich später auch mit der
unabhängigkeitsbewegung von 19 910 da
kam ähnliches logans dhaka waren
ähnliche gedichte wurden auf dem dach
wäre zitiert das war eine sehr
ereignisreiche zeit hier kommen wir
kommen darauf zurück und werden uns auch
noch
die die lage der medien und der
medienberichterstattung in dieser zeit
anschauen
ich würde jetzt gerne monika bolliger
fragen sie waren auch ab juni 2011 vor
allem in der region sie waren
nz korrespondentin haben waren betraut
mit dem nahost chaussee und hatten dann
ihre erste zeit in jerusalem verbracht
man muss auch sagen diese ausbrüche der
revolution beginnend mit tunesien
übergeschwappt nach ägypten hat dann in
kürzester zeit praktisch die gesamte
arabische welt erfasst und wir schauen
uns mal an wie groß diese welt denn ist
sie waren also in jerusalem stationiert
wie haben denn die menschen in israel
palästina und in den umliegenden ländern
auf das reagiert was in tunesien und
ägypten abgelaufen ist
ja also ich meine israel ist vielleicht
ein bisschen ein spezial verlor ich die
israeli haben dann eher ein bisschen
besorgt geschah etwas passiert umbrüche
revolutionen können die stabilität
bedeuten für sie vielleicht neue neue
regierungen und dann wie geht man damit
um also das war vielleicht ein bisschen
jetzt eine andere sicht als als jetzt
die palästinenser und in den arabischen
nachbarländern nötig sagen ich glaube am
anfang haben da wirklich viele viele
leute mitgefiebert es gab auch eine fast
24 stunden berichterstattung in diesen
europäischen fernsehsendern und rasierer
und so weiter oder und und und da haben
schon alle auch palästinenser haben
irgendwie bloße hoffnung gehabt dass das
für die region eben eben sehr viel
verändern wird im positiven sinne aus
dass das ein jahr der emanzipation
vielleicht der menschen in diesen
ländern bedeuten könnte und dann auch
vielleicht mehr mitbestimmung ebenen
über die politische richtung die diese
region jetzt nimmt was ist aus ihrer
sicht aus diesen hoffnungen geworden
jetzt nur in dieser kurzen zeit mal ab
2011 12 ja ich denke viele hoffnungen
wurden brutal enttäuscht auch im fall
und es gibt schon auch so diese
resignation denke ich unter vielen
leuten und
diejenigen die ältere generation dort
heißt es auch so ein bisschen ja was
wolltet ihr mit eurer revolution das hat
ja nur irgendwie noch mehr instabilität
noch mehr wirtschaftsprobleme gebracht
und bei den jungen sind zum teil auch
schuldgefühle vielleicht da oder weil
man denkt man hat das angestoßen dass so
viel zerstörung am ende mit sich
gebracht hat man muss sagen diese
zerstörung kamen vor allem von den
regime selber nicht hunden nicht so sehr
von den demokratiebewegungen aber im
endeffekt ist das passiert das war sind
sehr viele schlimme dinge passiert und
insofern ja gibt es sicher viel
resignation aber man kann sich auch
feststellen dass das sich trotzdem auch
etwas verändert hat und dass dieser
prozess nicht abgeschlossen ist also ich
finde es immer ein bisschen einfach wenn
man sagt ja
der arabische frühling das war noch
schön aber das ist jetzt halt
gescheitert es ist eine sehr kurze zeit
und ich glaube solche umbrüche die
verlaufe nicht linear und sowas braucht
zeit und was ich auf jeden fall
verändert hat ist dass ich eben diese
diese ganze generation die damit gemacht
hat die die ist politisiert worden durch
diese durch diese umbrüche
wir schauen noch einmal etwas zurück
jeanette müller als sie in ägypten waren
zwischen 2011 und 2013 haben sie an den
blog geschrieben über die ereignisse sie
haben darüber berichtet was sie was sie
sehen mit gesprächen die sie geführt
haben mit vielen menschen und so weiter
dieser blog action letters nennen sie
ihn
der ist immer noch online man kann immer
noch nachlesen da ist mir aufgefallen
die erste seite schreiben sie sozusagen
einen nachruf auf eine interessante
figur die in ägypten und in der
arabischen welt eine große bekanntheit
hat jamal p banner
wer ist das und warum hat sie dieser
mann so nachhaltig beeindruckt ich habe
jamal al banna dreimal getroffen und
drei mal interviewt er war einer meiner
ersten interviewpartner im jahr 2007 als
ich nach kairo gekommen bin und
anna ist der jüngste bruder des
muslimbruderschaft begründers hassan al
banna und war damals in den dreißiger
jahren auch involviert in die erstellung
der zeitschrift der muslimbrüder im
ersten anlauf wo die regierung dann
versucht hat die muslimbrüder
loszuwerden und sie massiv inhaftiert
nicht zuletzt nach einem attentat auf
einen christlichen politiker in in
ägypten
danach hat er sich zurückgezogen nach
seiner gefängnis erfahrung und ist
eigentlich dann zu einem sozialisten
geworden er hat anfragen er wollte einen
islamischen sozialismus predigen und hat
dann relativ viel geld geerbt und hat in
einem sehr bescheidenen in einer
bescheidenen wohnung in kairo gelebt und
zwischen tausenden von büchern
es war für mich der idealtypische
intellektuelle er hat nur fürs schreiben
uns denken geliebt und er hat gesagt
dass es sehr wichtig ist dass man in der
islamischen welt dass ein umdenken
stattfindet im islam und er wollte einem
neuen krieg begründen eine neue
islamische jurisprudenz die angepasst
sein kann
andy antimoderne und hat entsprechend
bücher geschrieben zu themen wie zb der
verschleierung der frau hat sich dafür
ausgesprochen dass junge frauen wenn sie
denn tatsächlich islamische vorschriften
zur verschleierung achten möchten dass
zum beispiel in westlichen ländern auch
tun können indem sie eine mütze
aufziehen und einen rollkragenpulli dass
das islamisch konform sei er hat auch
eine schrift gefertigt darüber dass
frauen die predigt leiten können dass es
immer einen gegen gegeben kann
er hat sich massiv dafür eingesetzt dass
mädchen junge mädchen nicht beschnitten
werden sollen
und in diesem sinne ist er eigentlich
ein wichtiger islamischer vordenker und
kann nicht mehr mit der
muslimbruderschaft in kontakt gebracht
werden in seiner späteren leistung ich
habe ihnen als sich in der interview
habe fand ich das auch immer spannend er
hat nie gesagt mein bruder hassan al
banna er hat immer gesagt hat gemacht
die muslimbrüder haben das und das
gemacht aber nie ich habe oder mein
bruder also hat sich völlig davon
distanziert
und er hat mich wirklich sehr
beeindruckt weil er einfach sehr sehr
gut und sehr einfach seine anliegen
formulieren konnte uns eigentlich auch
gut für eine breite masse in ägypten
hätte erreichen können
das wurde aber leider untergraben weil
er auch von den medien nachhaltig
dargestellt wurde als senile alter greis
clown der nation also man hat ihn dann
eigentlich nicht mehr ernst genommen
weil zu einem späteren zeitpunkt
tatsächlich eben die muslimbrüder
offensichtlich sehr erfolgreich waren
damit eine konservative eine
konservative ansicht des islams zu
stellen
sie haben jetzt eben die frauen thematik
schon angesprochen und das gibt mir die
möglichkeit jemand ganz konkret
nachzufragen bei ihnen frau b liga ist
man sich eigentlich in der arabischen
welt nach ihrer erfahrung einig mit der
westlichen welt dass die frauenfrage der
gradmesser ist die gretchenfrage ist für
den zustand von demokratie und den
zustand der gesellschaft schlechthin zu
beschreiben
also ich würde und westliche welt nicht
so gegenüberstellen ich glaube auch bei
uns ist man sich da nicht so einig ob
das der gradmesser ist oder nicht
ich persönlich finde schon dass es ein
guter gradmesser ist weil weil ich
glaube schon jetzt in bezug auf die
mitbestimmung im arabischen raum sind ja
schon sehr harter schale ordnungen
vorhanden und diese gehören auch sind
auch teil von diesen von diesen
autokratien diese funktionieren sie
haben an der spitze in der regel in eine
art vaterfigur und dann die religiöse
autoritäten und so weiter und um die
frauen sind dann ein bisschen wie das
schwächste glied in dieser ganzen kette
und im arabischen frühling gab es ist
das alles ein bisschen durcheinander
gepurzelt
und da gab es plötzlich räume wo die auf
gingen wo die leute irgendwie neue
rollen einnehmen konnten wo sie sich neu
erfinden konnten die gesellschaft neu
denken konnten und da gab es plötzlich
auch ganz viel platz für die frauen also
tun da auch verschiedene rollen
einzunehmen
und inzwischen ist leider dieser raum
wieder wieder verschwunden
also bürgerkriege repression
geopolitische konflikte und so weiter
aber das gab einen moment gab es diesen
raum und ich glaube schon dass man das
ein bisschen so festmachen kann daran
oder wie
sobald auch die frauen mit denen das ist
die hälfte der bevölkerung
und ich glaube diese systeme
funktionieren auch im wissen sodass das
man eben zuoberst dieses obere überhaupt
hat und dann und dann so diese
hierarchien und dann das
familienoberhaupt und und alle können
ein bisschen nach unten ein bisschen
kontrolle ausüben oder macht ausüben und
die frauen die sind dann quasi ja an
unterster stelle sozusagen oder und ja
dass ich dann wenn das wenn das sich so
ein bisschen verschiebt dann heißt das
für die frauen mehr mitbestimmung haben
aber auch für alle denken und die
bereitschaft ist auch in den familien
vorhanden
für diese veränderung ja also es ist
natürlich schwierig oder weil es gibt so
eine eine erziehung und das ist in den
schulen und in fremden familien die über
jahrzehnte den leuten beigebracht hat
nicht kritisch zu sein gegenüber neben
dem oberhaupt dem vater auch
meinungsverschiedenheiten nicht sie
nicht zugelassen kritische fragen in der
schule sind nicht zugelassen und soll
auswendiglernen und und keine fragen
stellen oder und und ich glaube das zu
verändern es gabe dann im rahmen des
arabischen frühlings das waren ja immer
situations bewegungen gegen diese idee
also gegen die idee dass man einfach
gehorchen soll und dass ich ein
wichtiger moment aber bis das dann
wirklich sich in der ganzen gesellschaft
niederschlägt und ändert dass bach
glaube ich sehr lange also nur zur
erinnerung in der schweiz
frauenstimmrecht ist vor 50 jahren auch
angenommen worden und und vor 50 jahren
haben die schweizer männer sind die zum
schluss gekommen ja doch dass die hälfte
die andere hälfte der bevölkerung auch
politisch mitreden darf und also ich
glaube einfach solche die sich solche
vorstellungen
verändern braucht das braucht es sehr
sehr viel zeit und viel kraft und
energie und einsatz herz und einsatz zu
sagen etwas wichtiges ich möchte
vielleicht zu folgendem hinweis kommen
ich konnte vor dieser sendung mit der
tunesischen filmemacher in ramallah
sprechen und ich habe sie gefragt was
ich für ein heft verhältnis zu ihrer
heimat hat uns zu ihrem schaffen und die
frau infrage gestellt schauen wir uns
das kurz an
[Musik]
ich bin in tunesien aufgewachsen und
habe teilweise dort studiert danach bin
ich nach frankreich gezogen wo ich
meinen film studium abgeschlossen haben
ich habe mich dafür entschieden sowohl
in frankreich wie in tunesien zu drehen
jeder versucht sein gleichgewicht zu
finden
es passt gesehen die ihre rolle auch als
übersetzerin zwischen den kulturen nicht
wirklich ich sehe mich nicht als
sprachrohr einer kultur nicht
interessiert der mensch in seiner ganzen
komplexität besonders interessieren mich
frauenfiguren
denn sie stehen heute vor sehr wichtigen
fragen
ich versuche sie auf diesem besonderen
wert der entfaltung zu begleiten einer
sich verändernden welt deren grundfesten
erschüttert sind arbeiter gerne aus
dieser haltung heraus dass tunesien von
heute ein besseres land für die frauen
die frage ist sehr vielschichtig ist der
situation besser für die frauen ist sie
besser für die frauen ins team
[Musik]
sowohl als auch daneben gibt es das
geopolitische umfeld und die weltweite
krise die pandemie die attentate wie den
tourismus zum erliegen gebracht haben
das land erlebt zurzeit eine sehr
schwierige periode in der vieles
hinterfragt wird
positiv zu vermerken sind neue gesetze
die erlassen worden sind und die rechte
der frauen gestärkt haben und gewalt
gegen frauen bestrafen anderes wurde
bisher nicht umgesetzt
die gleiche erbschaftsrecht diese
komplexe frage lässt sich also nicht so
einfach beantworten
das land befindet sich auf einem weg
vieles ist im fluss und so ist es
unmöglich eine klare bilanz zu ziehen
sie haben interessante forschung gemacht
in jemen geht es weniger um die
städtischen verhältnisse sondern um das
verhalten der stämme und die frauenfrage
erzählen sie uns davon
ja also forschung ist dann wissen
übertrieben aber ich habe in einem
projekt mitgearbeitet wo wir uns das ein
bisschen an geschaut haben und auch mit
mitte forschenden gesprochen haben zu
diesem thema und da ging es eigentlich
vor allem darum was was frauen gehen
stammesgesellschaften für eine rolle in
der friedensförderung spielen könnten
und da haben wir viele spannende sachen
einig gesehen also diese gesellschaften
sind sie aber zwei mal organisiert oder
und es gibt eine ganz klare
rollenverteilung für männer und frauen
aber das heißt nicht wie man vielleicht
hier manchmal die erwartung hat was
daneben die frauenrolle passiv ist und
dass das irgendwie opfer sind die zu
hause sitzen und nicht aus dem haus
gehen und gar nichts machen können
sondern vielmehr ist es eigentlich so
dass gerade auf dem land oder wo
inländischen gesellschaften die die
frauen sehr viel aus dem haus clean und
sehr viel auch klassen machen in der
landwirtschaft zum beispiel und dass er
dann in den städten also eine
versteigerung stattfindet irgendwie dann
restriktiver wird für die frauen aus
dass die frauen dann eben er dann dass
es dann eher die sich das durchsetzt die
vorstellung dass die frau muss zu hause
sein
die sollten nicht rausgehen das
entspricht nicht unseren traditionen
oder aber die frage ist was ist was ist
tradition auch ein bisschen oder und und
dann haben wir auch leute auch gesagt
dass sie zu neuen festgestellt haben
dass das frauen wenn sie mehr bildung
genossen hatten im jemen dass sie dann
eigentlich eher zu hause bleiben oder er
verschwunden oder weniger nach draußen
gingen und das ist aber doch sehr
erstaunlich
wir hören hier seit jahren wenn nicht
jahrzehnten bildung ist das a und o für
die emanzipation der frauen und sie
erzählen uns jetzt hier quasi das
gegenteil hin also das möchte ich auch
nicht gestalten dass bildung das auch
das so ist aber es kommt vielleicht
darauf an welche bildung oder und und
wenn jetzt die bildung ebene von diesen
es gibt ist auch noch nicht so alt diese
diese religiösen bewegungen oder diese
wende zu mehr religiosität ist ein paar
jahrzehnte jetzt her
in der region dieser trend und und das
hat sich auch in der bildung
niedergeschlagen also dass man halt eben
diese diese werte predigt die man auch
aus traditionen verkauft die aber zum
teil gar nicht so alte traditionen
sender oder oder zumindest nicht in
dieser gefestigten form aus dass es
immer so klar ist oder und ich glaube
nicht dass also die frauen sind
überhaupt nicht gleichberechtigt in den
stammesstrukturen und ich möchte das
nicht irgendwie aus modell propagieren
wo alles toll ist und romantisieren aber
es war einfach spannend zu sehen dass
eben auch jetzt im jemen gibt es in
diesen gesellschaften frauen die auch
initiativen ergreifen und und eigentlich
auch in der mediation manchmal
erstaunliche sachen erreichen und
und gerade weil die frauen sind also
weil sie diese rolle haben haben sie
auch eine besondere stellung also sie
sind zum beispiel eben nicht also man
dort frau nicht angreifen auf keinen
fall oder wenn veränderte stimme wenn
der eine zum anderen geht und eine frau
dabei hat dann ist das eigentlich gegen
alle konventionen und und regeln diese
die diesen gegner irgendwie anzugreifen
dann muss man mit dem die fäden zum
beispiel und also ich bin wirklich nicht
experten in diesem themen aber ich fand
das sehr spannend dass er diese sachen
die wir die wir da gesehen haben und
einfach dass dieser gegensatz vielleicht
auch nicht immer so klar ist also was
wir als tradition anschauen und was wir
aus modernen anschauen und manchmal hat
die moderne im arabischen raum auch wie
eine festigung von gewissen
konservativen oder frauenfeindlichen
sitzen sozusagen herbeigeführt also dass
das plötzlich irgendwie aus als ganz
klar das ist unsere tradition ja
verkauft wurde was aber nur bedingt
stimmt und ich mein anderes beispiel in
saudi arabien gab es ja auch jetzt hat
sich das ein bisschen geändert aber ganz
lange war diese kleidervorschrift jahr
frauen müssen diese schwarze verhüllung
ganzkörperverhüllung mit je nach einem
gesichtsschleier aber nicht
obligatorisch aber fast alle haben es
immer getragen und ganz sicher einfach
schwarze schwarzer umhang und kopftuch
so und und das wurde dann aus quasi
saudische traditionelle kleidung
dargestellt aber wenn man schaut was was
ein bisschen zurückgeht und schaut was
es eigentlich für traditionelle kleidung
gab früher ins all ihrer bindung ist das
regional sehr verschieden und das kann
sehr bunt und farbenfroh sein und das
wurde irgendwann dann mal so
institutionalisiert als quasi ja
nationale identität für saudi arabien
und die frauen die müssen halt alle
irgendwie sich so kleiden weil das teil
der identität ist und wir sehen das auch
immer ein bisschen so ein mittel um wie
soll ich sagen also man hat auf der
einen seite hat man so ganz schnelle
rasante umbrüche in der region oder also
es gibt diese wirtschaftliche
transformation modernisierung
industrialisierung die sehr sehr schnell
vonstatten geht
wir haben ganz besonders sie haben die
beduinen in der wüste ein bisschen
zugespitzt nicht nur aber und dann
kommen die ölfirmen und plötzlich haben
sie hochhäuser wolkenkratzern und
hightech und digitale sie genau das ist
eigentlich extrem schnell alles passiert
und das ist vielleicht auch ein schock
für für die gesellschaften und dann ist
das doch irgendwie gut wenn man weil man
sich an irgendwie das noch festhalten
kann eine eine tradition oder was man
hat das tradition verkauft sozusagen und
um die frauen das ist halt einfach ein
gutes symbol das ist so sichtbar oder
und das ist auch die können sich am
wenigsten wehren gegen solche
bevormundung und ja die werden glaube
ich dann auch so ein bisschen die
symbole von von identität die rahmen
sich auch also nicht nur in diesem
zusammenhang bat müller würden sie das
würden sie das was wir jetzt aus dem
jemen und saudi-arabien gehört haben
auch auf ägypten übertragen dass die
ländliche bevölkerung in dem sinn nicht
unbedingt die gleichen die gleiche
lebensführung hat bei der frauenfrage
wie in städten
es ist natürlich klar dass in einfachen
verhältnissen in denen jeder zum erwerb
der familie seien weiter leisten muss
die frau natürlich mit arbeiten muss und
auch dann bestimmte rechte genießt es
eigentlich mit dem fortschritt mit dem
das eben tatsächlich nur eine person
arbeiten muss oder eine person von
vielen es ist ja polygamie in den
meisten islamischen ländern der welt
außer tunesien so viel ich weiß
natürlich gang und gäbe und recht von
nächtens für muslimische männer also
dass nur eine person arbeitet und vier
jahren versorgt das da muss man hier
einen gewissen wohlstand mit sich gegen
wohingegen wenn man zum beispiel als
paar oder als kleine familie einen
bäuerlichen betrieb führt dann kann man
sich das ja gar nicht leisten dass die
frau einfach zu hause sitzt und und den
koran liegen zb wohingegen also
tatsächlich diese vollverschleierung ist
natürlich auch ein markantes symbol
eigentlich des reichtums und des
wohlstands das heißt ich kann mir
leisten vollständig nach imaginärem
islamischen recht bedient zu werden also
dass da nehmen wir vielleicht aus
aus unserer westlichen warte auch eine
fehlinterpretation vor verstehe ich das
richtig
also es ist ich würde sagen einfach
diese spezifische also die unterdrückung
der frau
so wie wir sie wahrnehmen ist nicht
unbedingt immer geknüpft an jetzt
imaginäre vorstellung oder eine
bestimmte ideologie
sie geht natürlich auch mit sozial
kulturellen hintergründen einher
und wir haben selbstverständlich denke
ich in europa wird es häufig falsch
interpretiert was jetzt eine spezifische
kleidungs art zum beispiel von frauen
aussagen möchte
aus meiner perspektive und aus dem lot
viele arabischen muslimischen
frauenrechtlerin ist das ein symbol der
unterdrückung der frau aber die frau
trotzdem freiwillig das sind dinge die
natürlich komplex sind und nicht einfach
dass eine vom online getrennt werden
kann zunächst einmal als widersprüche
erscheint ja wir gehen noch einmal
zurück nach tunesien und zur
filmemacherin anna marie in ihrem
neuesten film she had a dream stellt sie
die junge schwarze tunesisch in refrath
ins zentrum die für ihre überzeugungen
in der familie und auf der straße
einträgt und die für die wahlen zum
nationalen parlament kandidiert
[Musik]
der film zeigt die schwierige
ausgangslage einer jungen frau als
schwarze toni siering ist sie
konfrontiert mit rassismus wie ihr für
den maghreb und einen teil der
arabischen welt typisch ist
dann stand sie aus einem benachteiligten
stadtviertel am stadtrand von tunis mit
großen wirtschaftlichen problemen
sie ist eine frau sie ist jung und sie
will etwas erreichen von dem sie eine
ahnung erhaschte als durch die
revolution hoffnung aufkeimt junge frau
steht sie mitten drin in einem
entscheidenden kampf
[Musik]
der film beleuchtet auch andere probleme
wie die hoffnungslosigkeit und den
vertrauensverlust der menschen in die
politik
ich versuche zu zeigen dass sie
ungeachtet dieser schwierigkeiten am
schluss nicht mit leeren händen dastehen
man sieht im film an verschiedenen
stellen dass die jungen ruf dann
erklären muss wie demokratie
funktioniert dass es zum beispiel ein
parlament mit vom volk gewählten
vertreterinnen und vertretern gibt
glauben sie dass man zu wenig bescheid
weiß über die demokratie
so würde ich es nicht sagen ich glaube
dass die tunesier das wesen der
demokratie verstehen sie wissen heute um
ihre rechte
sie wissen dass sie ihre stimme für oder
gegen einsetzen kann
[Musik]
im film hören wir wie ihr eine frau auf
dem markt sagt wir haben das recht
jemanden zu wählen und wenn er uns nicht
gefällt werden wir ihn einsetzen
es ist immer das volk das entscheidet
man spürt wie stark sich das tunesische
volk seiner macht bewusst geworden ist
die schwierigkeit steckt im äußerst
komplizierten wahlsystem
durch die ausübung der demokratie sind
sich die dinge aber am verändern
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
mir war es wichtig zu zeigen was dialog
jenseits des weit gefassten begriff der
demokratie bedeutet
mit dem einblick in die private welt der
familie sehen wir wie demokratie im
kleinen funktioniert
es gibt auch im kreis der familie
meinungsverschiedenheiten mit ihrem
bruder ihre mutter oder ihren cousins
und cousinen
das ist gut denn heute kann man
unterschiedliche meinungen äußern was
vorher nicht der fall war
sie haben gelacht oder geschmunzelt
bei der szene wo die junge kandidatin
ihren familienmitgliedern darlegen muss
was das eigentlich sollte dieses
kandidieren was hat sie daran so bewegt
also ich denke das sieht man schon auch
irgendwie den generationsunterschied
natürlich zum einen und auch irgendwie
eine schichtzugehörigkeit also die von
rhein von der kleidung her würde ich
jetzt sagen die familie die ist sehr
traditionell orientiert er ein aus
einfachen verhältnissen und die junge
dame die scheint er sich tatsächlich
sehr stark nach außen zu positionieren
eben mit ihrem politischen engagement
und das wird überhaupt nicht verstanden
weil natürlich in also jetzt in diesen
breitengraden offensichtlich die bildung
nicht vorhanden ist um das zu verstehen
und in dies und sie versucht das ja zu
erklären und aber die verwandtschaft
versteht das nicht die sagen aber gut
das könnte etwas gutes haben wenn das
mädchen jetzt so was macht
die besorgt uns einen führerschein und
das ist das ist so ein bisschen die
erwartung die natürlich an der die
demokratie auch in diesen ländern
scheitert das hat man auch gesehen zum
beispiel das jetzt als ich in ägypten
gelebt habe die revolution ging ja nicht
zu ende sondern alle haben demonstriert
und alle wollten sie was mehr lohn mehr
möglichkeiten und da das sind einfach es
waren so viele hoffnungen und und uns so
viele anforderungen die die konnten auch
ein stückweit nur enttäuscht werden
und also würden sie sagen diese
revolution ist an der masse der
verschiedenen forderungen letztlich
gescheitert in anführungszeichen nein
sie ist von militär und streichen und an
der weltpolitik wahrscheinlich
gescheitert ich glaube nicht ich glaube
wenn man das wenn man die tatsächlich
die die staaten gewähren lässt dass ich
find tunesien ist ein hervorragendes
beispiel es gab eine strafgesetz reform
die jetzt da die nach der jetzt ein
vergewaltiger nicht mehr für sein
verbrechen entlastet wird vollumfänglich
wenn er sein opfer heiratet das war
vorher auch im eigentlich nach außen
wirkenden fortschrittlichen tunesien
nächtens das ist es heute nicht mehr und
muslimische frauen in tunesien dürfen
jetzt auch vollkommen legal ein nicht
moslem heiraten das sind zwei eigentlich
bauen kirchende umgesetzte forderung der
frauenbewegung in tunesien
und da sieht man eben das in tunesien
wohl die nacht der partei ganz klar
gewählt wurde in der regierung ist auch
gegend ist der gesellschaft also die
islamistische konservative partei wenn
man ihr aber demokratisch auch grenzen
setzt und sich entgegen stellt ist es
möglich dass das land sich
weiterentwickelt das ist natürlich in
ägypten nicht der fall gewesen weil
ägypten hat man sich sofort ist sehr
stark darüber brüskiert dass jetzt ein
muslimbruder an der macht war
und dann war man hier auch eigentlich
irgendwie froh dass er dann mit mittels
militär staatsstreich wie er von der
macht entfernt worden ist das ist
natürlich keine chance hat man dieses
land überhaupt keine chance gegeben sich
vor zu entwickeln man hätte dem
demokratische maßnahmen
gegen stellen müssen und das hätte auch
von außen gefördert werden sollen
schauen wir uns noch ein bisschen die
rolle der religion an bei den
verschiedenen revolutionen und und in
der region überhaupt welche rolle hat
die religion konkret gespielt bei den
protest und bei der revolution in
ägypten sie haben uns material auch aus
dieser protest zeit mitgebracht da hat
man gesehen es gibt dieses hand in hand
gehen dass muslimischen halbmond
sozusagen mit dem christlichen kreuz wir
erinnern uns vielleicht auch an bilder
die wir gesehen haben damals wo
muslimische leute christliche leute
verteidigt haben vor dem gebet geschützt
haben und umgekehrt
da war eine große solidarität zwischen
den religiösen gruppen spürbar
monika bolliger ja das war am anfang so
und und mit der zeit gab es dann eine
gewisse spaltung als die muslimbrüder
daneben und der macht waren und
natürlich ist das eine vereinfachung
aber es gab schon ein bisschen diese
diese linie von den islamisten und den
säkularisten also den leuten die
irgendwie keine islamistische regierung
wollten um diejenigen die es wollten
und ja es stimmt also die die
muslimbrüder wurden dann am ende mit
einem militärputsch gestürzt und dabei
hatten sie aber auch sehr viel populären
support also es gab wieder
massendemonstrationen und die leute
wollten auch so viele leute wollten
einen sturz dieser regierung
ja man kann man kann sich ein bisschen
fragen wie das wie das alles gekommen
ist
das hat natürlich eine kampagne in allen
medien gegen die muslime sind für das
verantwortlich gemacht für
wirtschaftsprobleme die schon lange weit
zurück reichen die jetzt nicht unbedingt
ihre schuld waren oder die instabilität
die unsicherheit die zum teil darauf
zurückgehen dass eben die
sicherheitskräfte einfach nicht mehr
nicht bedauern und eben keine keine
sicherheit mehr gewährleistet haben also
eigentlich einfach nicht mitgespielt
haben
bei dieser regierung und und dann
und dann wurde das so ein bisschen
aufgepasst und und andererseits ist es
natürlich auch so dass die muslimbrüder
ihr hatte ich schon nicht den eindruck
dass sie jetzt sehr stark den dialog
suchen und dann kompromiss suchen also
dass sie auch so ein bisschen vielleicht
auch ein stück weit anders ticken aber
aber durch diese lange zeit wo sie wo
sie habe im untergrund waren und halb in
der opposition und immer mal wieder im
gefängnis
dass die halt auch so ein bisschen eine
mentalität entwickelt haben die ein
bisschen paranoid ist und und des
misstrauens und so und ich hatte schon
den eindruck dass sie auch am liebsten
eigentlich einfach dieses regime
kooptiert hat nun gesagt wir übernehmen
jetzt da diese dieses regime und dann
reagieren wir mal so und dann haben wir
unsere unsere vision eines islamisch und
einer islamischen herrscher was das
genau heißt weiß ja auch keiner
also das hat immer verwandte baum muss
man vielleicht auch sagen ja was dann im
einzelnen heißt genau also dass das ist
sowieso an ich meine immer eine große
frage was was das eigentlich heißt weil
weil wenn man mit all diesen islamisten
redet und das sind dass hier
verschiedene gruppierungen und leute
dann wird einem nie so richtig klar
finde ich wieder setzt im rahmen von
einem modernen nationalstaat das ist
aber heute genommen wie was das denn
eigentlich heißt das dass sie sie gehen
dann irgendwie sie reden vielleicht von
von der vergangenheit wo es islamische
reiche gab die aber auch vielvölker
staaten wollen und und eben nicht diese
moderne staatsform wo man ja irgendwie
bürokratien und grenzen und und register
und so weiter hat und institutionen in
dieser art und ja und in diesem kontext
ist mir nicht eigentlich bis heute nicht
so klar was eigentlich besonders an
einem islamischen staat sein soll auch
wie zum beispiel iran anschauen
iranische revolution das ist am ende ist
iran trotzdem eine republik und es gibt
ein parlament und es gibt waren es gibt
eine flache als künftigen grenzen es
gibt also dieser rahmen der ist
irgendwie da und und dann gibt es
irgendwie
macht man vielleicht gesetze wird bei
denen man sich irgendwie auf eine
auslegung des islam beruft zum beispiel
oder ja so forschen die auch kosmetisch
zum teil an sind und um dann nennt man
das im islam ist aber ich weiß nicht was
ich finde es nicht so eine eine
spektakuläre aus der native zu anderen
regime minute und das ist ja auch nicht
so dass die sogenannt nicht
islamistischen oder säkularistischen
regime dann dass es dort unbedingt mehr
freiheit geht oder dass die minderheiten
dort unbedingt immer also das haben auch
die zeit unter ben ali gezeigt oder die
zeit von ihrem haus seien gezeigt und
hafis al-assad olga seinem sohn gezeigt
also es ist wie keine wirkliche
alternative
ja also ich sehe einfach auch den
unterschied nicht immer so gut aus also
nein ohne jetzt das aber ich ja klar
dass es ist eine eine diktatur ist nicht
toll und wenn es dann noch eine
islamistische diktatur ist es ist
vielleicht also ja vielleicht noch
schlimmer keine ahnung aber ich kannte
man kann einfach nicht das nicht immer
so klar gegenüberstellen
ich zum beispiel in ägypten gerade war
so dass das unter sich aus unter dem
jetzigen regime unter dem jetzigen
militärregime schule verfolgt wurden und
immer noch verfolgt werden es gab eine
hetzkampagne und verhaftungen eine zeit
lang und in diesem ausmaß gab es das
unter der muslimbrüder nicht und ich
will nicht sagen dass das nicht passiert
wäre wenn sie sich besser etabliert
hatten das weiß man einfach nicht einen
so genannten säkulares ihm garantiert
noch nicht dass es deswegen eben für
frauen und für minderheiten immer
unbedingt besser aussieht dass das ist
ja was wir eigentlich ein bisschen davon
ausgehenden habe ich ja ich würde gerne
noch etwas dazu fügen also ich denke
auch natürlich diese gesellschaften in
dem jahr sind konservativ islamisch
geprägt das haben wir bereits am anfang
festgehalten aus der patriarchalisch
natürlich auch mit einhergehend und was
man sich erhofft von einer islamischen
republik oder von einem islamistischen
regime ist natürlich dass die politiker
dann entsprechend integer
und nicht korrupt handeln nach der
religion die natürlich dass die man aus
das höchste empfindet dass man hat also
man muss das ja vor gott verantworten
was man tut er hofft man sich
entsprechend dass das eben zu einer
anderen politik führt als die die man
gewohnt ist von von von den man sieht's
auch bei abt als sie sie wieder mit dem
neubau eines wunderbaren
präsidentenpalais es also das äußerst
sich ja auch diese diese maßlosen
ausgaben die sieht ja auch dass die
bevölkerung und und schätzt die nicht
und will dem etwas entgegensetzen und da
setzt man natürlich auf auf gott als
höchste instanz und auf die religion
also die frage nach der moralischen
integrität einer einer regierung bilden
sie ab schauen wir uns mal an die sich
eigentlich in der arabischen welt die
religiosität der leute entwickelt das
umfrageinstitut art barometer hat zahlen
oder bringt zaun und regelmäßig heraus
die britische bbc hat die grafisch
aufbereitet und hier sehen wir zwar im
vergleich der zahlen aus 2013 das sind
die grünen punkte und die verschiebung
in richtung weniger religiosität das
heißt die leute sagen heute häufiger in
vielen arabischen ländern dass sie sich
als nicht religiös bezeichnen das heißt
wir haben hier eine veränderung
hinrichtung entfremdung der religion
oder also richtung säkularisierung das
müsste das müsste man wahrscheinlich im
einzelnen noch anschauen
aber was fehlt ihnen denn sonst an
dieser grafik auf monika poliker ja aus
ich glaube schon dass das problem ist
immer es gibt es sehr wenige umfragen
das ist eine der wenigen und ich weiß
nicht wie sie das überhaupt schaffen
diese umfragen auch durchzuführen
in diesen kontexten die ja nicht frei
sind
aber ich glaube ja ich hatte schon auch
den eindruck dass das jetzt durch
gewisse erfahrungen mit mit islamisten
also mit leuten die politik irgendwie
religiös legitimieren dass das auch ein
stück weit bei den bei manchen leuten
dazu geführt hat dass sie sich ebenfalls
abgewandt haben aber das ist eine these
ich kann das nicht bestätigen ich habe
einfach ich habe leute getroffen die das
so erzählt haben und und das so
begründen dass sie sagen ja religion ist
irgendwie ein machtinstrument oder die
religiösen haben auch versagt darin
und bevor es überhaupt jetzt dazu kam
dass das religiöse parteien die macht
übernehmen könnten es gibt ja immer noch
sehr wenig beispiele waren die halt auch
hatten sich vielleicht mehr
glaubwürdigkeit im sinne von eben das
eben auch nicht korrupt galten und und
in ägypten aus über die muslimbrüder
hatten immer diese diese charity
aktivität oder dass sie das ist ihre
herkunft ihr sagen ja also sie waren
schon auch eine eine ja eine eine
größere bewegung aber das ist schon dass
ein kerngeschäft war war sicher in der
in der wohlfahrts tätigkeit in schulen
und spitälern usw
das wurde auch in indy präsidenten
gebeten die hamas gewählt einmal oder
und und die muslimbrüder ich glaube
kunden darauf bauen
und ja es scheint schon so dass sie in
ägypten dann wissen in misskredit
gefallen sind aber ich glaube auch dass
zugleich durch diesen putsch und und das
vor allem das massaker was nachher
geschehen ist also wo und die
sicherheitskräfte über 1000 anhänger der
muslimbrüder wirklich umgebracht haben
an einem tag
das hat sie schon auch wieder ein stück
hat in einem rtl rolle gedrängt und und
da gab es eben schon auch eben wieder
diese diese extreme spaltung in der
gesellschaft also die einen die einfach
sagten ja zum glück sind wir die
muslimbrüder jetzt los und und diese
spinne und was weiß ich
fanatiker und und die anderen geben da
drin steckten und und leute verloren
haben und nicht verstehen konnten
warum jetzt irgendwie der rest der
bevölkerung das unterstützt also dass
das land und da gab's glaube ich auch
eine gewisse radikalisierung auf der
anderen seite und das kann man wiederum
nicht messen ja also ich umfragen und so
sind schwierig
ob man weiß von fällen von von jüngeren
muslimbrüdern die dann sich eads
zugewandt haben zb also aus dieser
gewalt erfahrung heraus oder natürliche
sie sagten ja vermitteln das ist jetzt
nichts mehr nachdem wir in diese
erfahrung gemacht und ja insgesamt weiß
ich nicht ob die ob ihr gehirn schon
abschreiben können in der in der region
als politische kraft und und was ja was
er vielleicht auch noch auffällt ist
dass die nordafrikanischen länder eine
größere verschiebung haben währen denn
die europäischen kernländer sozusagen
eigentlich immer noch mehr oder weniger
unverändert bleiben wie ist das zu
interpretieren
also ich denke das gilt auch für eine
extreme polarisierung der gesellschaft
also aus tunesien besucht habe im jahr
2011 da sind wir zusammengekommen mit
kunstschaffenden und dann sind wir
gleichzeitig wurde auf der einen seite
von der avenue bourguiba
da steht das große theater da haben die
kunstschaffenden demonstriert und die
landeshymne gesungen und dann sind alles
also in afghanisten ch die outfit
herangezogene jugendliche aufgezogen und
haben sich in die mitte gestellt und
habe haben gefühlt erscheint juli
treffer islam also das volk das will ein
islamisches kalifat und die sind dann
also zusammengeklebt und die sind auch
aus diesen tagen dann patroulliert diese
jugendlichen haben den leuten in cafés
gesagt sie seien alles sofort weil sie
hier sitzen umbringe konsumieren genau
also dass das war schon also da hat man
das auch rechtlich gesehen wie das
aufeinander kleist und ich glaube nicht
zuletzt tunesien sieht man das auch noch
mal an der zahl der ausgesetzten ins
gebiet es handelt sich nämlich um die
prozentual gesehen höchste zahl der
ausgereisten aus ausländischen staaten
und ich denke dass es tatsächlich ein
riesenproblem wenn die eine seite des
landes haut richtung mehr
säkularisierung geht und die anti sich
vollständig radikalisieren und gerade
anhand der muslimbrüder können wir das
beobachten seit eigentlich ihrer
gründung und später vor allem in den
zeiten der
der präsidentschaft und gemmel abdel
nasser in der zeit wurden nämlich die
islam die die muslimbrüder und schwester
massiv verfolgt sie wurden in
gefängnissen bis zum wahnsinn gefoltert
und ermordet sagt krupp der wurde wurde
gehängt und er hat natürlich seid kommt
ist ein ideologe der derzeit sehr
wichtig ist immer noch im islamistischen
denken für für für salafistische
bewegung auch für für terroristen
er wird immer wieder zitiert und er hat
seine ganzen islamistischen
extremistischen schriften im gefängnis
geschrieben das ist ein riesengroßes
problem
und wenn weiter die islamisten derart
verfolgt werden und ins gefängnis
gesteckt werden ohne er ohne echte dann
die radikalisiert man die nicht sondern
man hier die kollidiert sie und ich
finde es sehr schade beobachten zu
müssen wie man ganz offensichtlich aus
diesen erfahrungen der diktaturen der
sozialistisch parodistischen diktatur
überhaupt nichts gelernt hat sondern
einfach jetzt im grunde genommen
weiterhin die die die die starken männer
in der arabischen welt massiv mit
milliarden unterstützt und und und da
eigentlich keine kritik äußert das
bringt mich zum nächsten punkt
was sind denn die erwartungen der
menschen im arabischen raum an die
westlichen regierungen und
gesellschaften monika boniek ja ich
glaube die erwartungen sind nicht mehr
so bewusst oder beziehungsweise
natürlich doch gibt es manchmal leute
die sich unterstützung erhoffen für für
für anliegen die menschenrechte und
demokratie und es gibt aber auch an
einen gewissen zynismus glaube ich oder
eine eine ja sagen wir mal vorstellungen
das hat westliche mächte sag jetzt mal
mit einer doppelmoral politisieren in
der region also dass man halt dass man
die einen kritisiert wegen
menschenrechtsverletzungen und
vielleicht sanktionen auch einführt und
so weiter und mit den anderen macht man
waffengeschäfte und und und die leute
sind ja nicht irgendwie sehen ja dass es
nicht immer mit gleichen ellen gemessen
wird und dass vor allem außenpolitik ist
am ende auch interessenpolitik aber
gleichzeitig gibt es dann diesen diskurs
westlicher mächte die sagen ja wir
stehen ein für menschenrechte und für
demokratie und was sie machen ist aber
eigentlich interessenpolitik oder und
und das nehmen die leute war und die
leute nehmen auch war das dass das eben
westliche mächte hier und dort eine
rolle spielen dass sie dass sie gewisse
gewisse regimes stützen würden sie das
bestätigen
auf jeden fall also ich denke man
diskreditiert sich hat tatsächlich in
dem das man spezifische menschenrechts
feindliche strukturen und korrupte
strukturen unterstützt und gleichzeitig
versuchte demokratie zu schädigen also
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ich war
mir auch daraus bei irakkrieg dem
amerikanisch initiieren nicht ganz
sicher wie ist das zu verstehen ist wir
kriegen euch die demokratie mit panzern
und mit mit armeen dieser einfall mit
gefängnissen wie auch extreme menschen
für menschenrechtsverletzungen vollzogen
worden sind was soll das wasser soll die
arabische bevölkerung daraus lernen also
wenn ihr hierher kommt und uns
demokratie hängt dann solltet ihr uns im
gefängnis die frage ist vielleicht auch
was können wir hier in europa davon
lernen weil die haben natürlich
resultierend aus diesen umbrüchen auch
immer mehr menschen die ihren
angestammten arabischen raum verlassen
wir haben hier noch eine grafik die das
aufzeigt gezeigt dass doch die
bereitschaft in vielen arabischen
ländern
die heimat zu verlassen gestiegen ist
was ändert das für uns also ich finde
das völlig verständlich weil die jungen
leute die damals und da vielleicht noch
mal auf meinen filmmaterial
zurückzukommen ich fand dass unglaublich
wie diese jungen leute sich bei form
eine kammer hergestellt haben gesagt wir
machen jetzt die zukunft ich war in der
universität von st er sieht das ist ja
auch das ist der ort wo auch modus her
kam an der universität hat der literatur
schaffende getroffen und war im
in einem club dabei der studenten die
gedichte rezitiert haben und ich habe
mit diesen jungen menschen mit diesen
jungen menschen gesprochen und die haben
mir gesagt sie verstehen nicht warum im
westen man denkt sie seien terroristen
oder sie seien irgendwie gefährlich
sie wollen ja jetzt nur irland aufbau
sie wollen alles dazu beitragen dass
irland etwas wird sie haben sich auf
über facebook zusammengefunden um die
straßen aufzuräumen zu streichen
sie haben wirklich mein mann hat der
diesen aufwand gesehen
man hat versucht man hat hier zum
beispiel man hat dann so solche
broschüren herausgegeben und um die
zivilbevölkerung darüber aufzuklären was
für rechte sie haben man versucht
demokratie und menschenrechte zu lernen
auf einfache art hier mit karikaturen
illustriert damit dass alle verstehen
können und das hat dass es ist einfach
sehr sehr traurig zu sehen dass das
natürlich nicht hat umgesetzt werden
können und ich denke dass viele jetzt da
wir aus logischerweise ableiten gut dann
müssen wir irgendwas machen wo wir
weiterkommen weil in diesen staaten geht
es ja nicht weiter also ist derzeit ist
die menschenrechts bedingungen in
ägypten sind eigentlich schlimmer als
damals zu zeiten von mubarak und auch
wir haben das kann ich vielleicht an
dieser stelle sagen versucht mit leuten
aus ägypten in kontakt zu treten und sie
zu gewinnen für ein interview aber das
war nicht möglich weil die angst einfach
zu groß ist vielleicht ein beispiel
könnte ich noch anfügen also ganz kurz
zwei beispiele was er hier das ist eine
kritik an mubarak aus sie aus dem jahr
damals wurde auch religiös argumentiert
weil so argumentiert sich tatsächlich in
diesen diesem kulturjahr um am besten
der koran sagt uns nicht dass wir
mubarak gehorchen müssen also das heißt
diese kritik gab es im jahr 2010 am 25
januar
dieses jahr ist also eigentlich zur
feier zu zehnjährigen feier der
revolution wurde ein wurde aus
schaafheim die verhaftet das ist ein
karikaturist ein influenza würde man
sagen mit einer gefolgschaft von
ungefähr drei millionen auf seinen
social media kanälen und der hat
versucht zur gleichen zeit
diese revolutionäre bewegung zu erinnern
eigentlich das zu machen was wir hier
gerade tun
über den arabischen frühling zu reden er
wurde verhaftet
also man kann eigentlich gar nicht mehr
nur schon das thema ansprechen in diesen
in diesen ländern und das finde ich sehr
sehr sehr sehr schlimm
wir haben schon fast am ende und
versendung eine letzte frage an sie frau
bolliger sie treten bald ihre stelle als
nahostkorrespondent in einem spiegel an
wo werden sie stationiert sein ich werde
ich wäre bei der aktion arbeit und hohe
spiegel ja und ich werde den aus
berichterstattung dort verstärken was
erwarten sie denn an entwicklungen in
der nächsten zeit für die region
ich glaube der region macht im moment
sehr sehr tiefen umbrüche durch und
nicht nur die region ich glaube die
ganze welt und wir befinden uns im
moment mitten drin und ich glaube es ist
sehr schwer zu erkennen was eigentlich
genau der mund herum passiert ja in
vieler hinsicht aber im endeffekt ich
glaube einfach die faktoren die dazu
geführt haben dass diese proteste von
2011 begonnen und danach 2009/10 liegen
immer noch da also zunehmend junge
bevölkerung große jugendarbeitslosigkeit
extreme korruption mafia ähnliche
regimes oder die die wirklich parasitär
zum teil sind und sicherheitsapparate
die die leute erniedrigen
anstatt sie zu beschützen das wäre
eigentlich die aufgabe von
sicherheitskräften und alles ist da und
hat sich eigentlich eher verschärft und
und insofern glaube ich nicht dass die
jetztige ordnung bestand hat und das ja
das muss nicht heißen dass morgen alles
ganz gut wird man das wird er glaube ich
eine schwierige zeit also sie rechnen
mit weiteren erschütterungen
wahrscheinlich und ich möchte hier am
schluss der sendung noch auf zwei bücher
hinweisen nämlich auf eines des
orientalisten und journalisten daniel
gerlach der nahe osten geht nicht unter
und er sieht die arabische welt vor
einer historischen chance hat also einen
etwas optimistischeren blick und das
zweite buch heißt the way around
und enthält essays von arabischen
journalistinnen die in der region und
über die region berichten
mir bleibt es ihnen ganz herzlich zu
danken dass sie in unserer sendung
gekommen sind vielen dank monika
bolliger und jan etwa einen anderen
blick in die region wird der film den
wie ihnen um 12 uhr in der sternstunde
kunst zeigen der foto schatz aus gaza
wird sie beeindrucken
zuvor aber spricht in der sternstunde
philosophie wolfram eilenberger mit der
schriftstellerin thea dorn über verlust
und einsamkeit ihnen einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]